foreign
and its relevance to human welfare why
it matters
and I want to start with what economics
is
economics is not the study of the
economy that's one of the many different
things that can be done with economics
economics is a way of understanding
behavior and it's defining
characteristic at least in my view is
that it is based on the Assumption of
rationality which means the assumption
that individuals have objectives and
tend to take the actions that best
achieve them
it's not entirely true
but it's generally the best we can do
especially for predicting the behavior
of large numbers of strangers I can do
better than that perhaps for predicting
my behavior maybe even my wife and kids
but not yours
why it might work better than one might
expect given that people are not
perfectly rational
one reason is that in many contexts the
effect of average irrationality the
effect of irrationality if it's random
averages out so if half the people spend
offer to buy a hamburger for more than
is worth and have for Less on average
you get about the same result as if
everybody got it right Worth to them
second in many contexts the people are
selected by the market for their rules
if I were running Microsoft it's
unlikely that I could figure out what to
do to maximize its profit but that's one
reason that I'm not the person Mac
running Microsoft all right
rationality although economists are
usually dealing with humans is not
limited to humans cats are rational if
you are reading your newspaper when you
should be petting the cat the cat solves
the problem by lying down on the
newspaper
I doubt that it understands what reading
is this may be a result of trial and
error it did it once and it worked and a
lot of our rationalities also trial and
error that you try different things the
ones that work you do again
babies are rational
imagine you're a baby some of you have
probably been babies Once Upon a Time
uh you have only one tool for
controlling the world your voice
so when you are wet or hungry you make
loud unpleasant noises and some one of
the big people comes and solves the
problem
given your constraints that's rational
Behavior let me give you one of my
favorite examples of the application of
Economics outside what most people think
of as economics and that's to Warfare in
fact I'll give you two examples
imagine that you are one of a thousand
one of ten thousand men a thousand years
ago somewhere in Europe and you're
holding Spears and you're all pointing
the spears that direction and the reason
you're pointing the spear is that
direction is that in that direction
there are another ten thousand men with
Spears on Horseback coming at you
and you do a very quick cost benefit
calculation
you figure that if all of you stand and
you keep your Spears braced with luck
you can break their charge and if you
break their charge some of you will die
but most of you will live if you run
away horses run faster than you do so
you should stand
no I made a mistake I thought in terms
of we
I don't control him and him I only
control me
if everybody else stands and I run
one fewer person in a line of 10 000 has
very very little effect on the chance
that will stop the charge and I won't be
one of the ones killed
if everybody else runs and I stand
I'm dead my only hope is to run first
and fastest
whatever everybody else is going to do I
am better off running
the result is that we all run and most
of us die welcome to the dark side of
rationality
and if you think about real military you
realize that one of the ways militaries
are organized to try to solve that
problem
perhaps the most famous example was the
Immortals of Thieves they were a group
of soldiers who consisted of pairs of
homosexual lovers no one of them would
ever show cowardice in present in the
presence of his beloved and they won
every battle they fought until the last
when they encountered an army led by
Philip of Macedon and his son Alexander
and they died to a man that at least is
the story
same logic occurs in Modern Warfare
suppose you are in a foxhole with a gun
and you're supposed to be looking around
for an enemy and shooting him but if you
do that you're quite likely to get
killed on the other hand if you go bang
bang bang bang
the officer won't know you're not doing
your job and the other people won't be
able to kill you and maybe that'll keep
their heads down
uh if you look at figures for Modern
Warfare the ratio of bullets fired to
men killed is enormous I think it
depends on Whose calculation you're
talking about something like 10 000 or
more bullets per per death and this
explanation this I think explains why
that's all economics it's just rational
Behavior
think of both of those as an example of
what economists call the public good
problem the problem of how you get
something produced when you can't
control who gets it on the battlefield
economics of politics
rational ignorance the market for favors
and short time for license
rationally ignorant failures that's most
of you
for democracy to work voters must stay
well informed
information is costly my vote almost
certainly won't affect the outcome
certainly won't because I'm in
California in the presidential election
California is certainly going to go for
Biden whatever I do
and if my vote by some very unlikely
chance does affect the outcome the
benefit of my having given a
well-informed vote is mostly shared with
my fellow citizens so I get very little
of it so for most voters the benefit to
them of getting the information
necessary to vote rationally is much
less than the cost to them and so most
voters are rationally ignorant
if voters are rationally ignorant and
they support the policies that sound
good to someone who knows little about
them and has no incentive to learn more
giving a politics of sound bites and
demagoguery I observe that from both
parties in my country and I suspect most
of You observe it from at least one
party perhaps from all parties except
your own in your country
the market for government favors what
determines what decisions governments
make who they benefit and who they harm
consider an auto tariff tariffs are an
interesting case because economists
concluded about 200 years ago that with
rare exceptions a tariff makes the
country then poses it worse off
an auto tariff benefits car makers and
their workers at the cost of consumers
and Farmers if we import fewer cars
we'll export less wheat
the beneficiaries are a few four firms
the auto companies and a union
and they all have a lot at stake the
losers are hundreds of billions of
people each losing a little
the beneficiaries can organize to offer
politicians support and campaign
contributions much more easily than the
losers can so it is politically
profitable to benefit concentrated
groups at the cost of dispersed groups
even if the cost is much larger than the
benefit and that explains quite a lot of
government policy in my country and I
suspect in your countries as well
short political time Horizons
politicians like to talk about how
important it is to deal with the future
and why you need their wisdom to prepare
for future problems
but if you think about their incentives
the incentive to Bear a cost now for a
benefit in the future depends on the
person who Bears the cost now getting
the benefit later so if I am investing
in planning a fruit tree which I've
planted quite a lot of I know at least
with reasonable luck and assuming not
too many fruit tree diseases that five
or ten years later I'll be getting fresh
fruit on the other hand a politician who
does politically costly things now
that provide a benefit 20 years later is
suffering political costs for himself in
order to benefit his successor 20 years
later but half the time will be of the
opposite party
does not sound like sensible decision so
if you watch what politicians do they
pretend to be interested in the future
because voters can't see the future so
it can be fooled into accepting real
costs now for Imaginary benefits then my
favorite example is Joseph Stalin who
could tell the Russians that it's true
their conditions were pretty difficult
and they had were crowding one family
into a room in Moscow
but they were suffering in order that
their children could be richer than the
Americans eventually people stopped
believing but it worked for a while
politicians decide what to do in a
democratic system by the effects on the
next election
economics of sex and marriage and here
I've got five categories the double
coincidence problem long-term contracts
rings and Promises contract default
polygamy and the price of a spouse
the double coincidence problem
barter markets work poorly at barter
Market you don't have any money you just
trade something for something else
if I want dinner on a barter Market I
have to find someone willing to cook me
dinner who wants to be taught economics
in exchange that is difficult to do
an ordinary Market with money one person
pays me to teach him economics and I use
the money to pay someone else for dinner
the problem with the dating sex marriage
Market is that it is inherently a barter
Market
if I am sleeping with you you are
sleeping with me if I am married to you
you are married to me so that means that
I have to find a woman who I want who
wants me and that is a harder problem
than finding one of each
the result is long search times many
frustrated people
why is marriage a long-term contract why
are there any long-term contracts
why don't we do everything as here's the
money give me the good
let's be married today we can worry
about tomorrow tomorrow
I take a job at UCLA move to Los Angeles
pay various costs of moving and getting
set up
UCLA has to fit me into their program
and that pays various costs I'm probably
not very productive in the first year or
two while they and I are learning the
ropes
now the department chairman calls me
into his office and he says the budget
is very tight we're thinking about
cutting your wage
after all I can't get back what I paid
to get there so it looks like I'm stuck
but of course they can't get back what
they lost on me in the first year either
so they're stuck too and that looks like
an opportunity for expensive bargaining
where I'm trying to push my wage up and
they're trying to push it down
bilateral Monopoly is what economists
call that situation one buyer one seller
it was a competitive market when I took
the job but once I've moved to Los
Angeles it's there's only one company
that wants to hire me there and I'm the
one person who's now sufficiently
learned how that department works so
they want to hire me so instead you have
an implicit or explicit long-term
Employment contract in the academic
world part of that is you don't cut
wages
I get married
my wife has to learn to live with me
which she can tell you was very
difficult I have to learn to live with
her which fortunately was pretty easy
we acquired joint property
it'd be costly to separate we've got a
house we're both living in
we have children we don't really want to
try to divide them up
so that's a bilateral Monopoly with
potential marketing costs and one
solution is to make marriage a long-term
contract to have either legal rules or
social expectations such that once you
are married threatening to get unmarried
is not considered a legitimate move in
the game except perhaps under very
extreme circumstances
engagement rings why do we have the
custom did we have I think it's
declining now of giving expensive rings
on engagement
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas